فما وثلاثون جائزه ابداعيه خمس منها ذهبيه
هكذا كرمت جائزه
العالميه قناه العربيه بين العديد من
المحطات العالميه المشاركه في الجائزه
الاكثر عراقه بعالم الفيديو
وكان لبرامج العربيه حضورها في نسخه
الجائزه الرابعه والاربعين لتحصد 19 جائزه
في فئات البرامج السياسيه والاجتماعيه
والثقافيه والتاريخيه والوثائقيه في
المسابقه التي شهدت مشاركه اكثر من 50
دوله من القارات الخمس وتعاملت مع ما يزيد
على 12 الف عمل اعلامي برنامج مهمه خاصه
كان حاضرا بقوه وذلك بعد ان اقتحم فريقه
العوالم المعتمه وخرج بتحقيقات واقعيه
ازالت الستر عن اعين المشاهد ووضعته في
صور كان مغيبا عنها
وفي عالم تملاه الصراعات سعى عسكري تاريا
الى نقل المشاهد الى قلب الاحداث الساخنه
وناقش الابعاد الاستراتيجيه والعسكريه
واستعرض اسلحه الماضي والحاضر والمستقبل
فحجز البرنامج مكانه متميزه له ولان
العربيه الاسم الذي اخترناه فقد حملنا على
كاهلنا العبء الكبير وهو حفظ التاريخ
المشرف وروايته والعوده الى الاصاله
وثقافه الاباء والاجداد فكان لنا حضورنا
ايضا مع برنامج على خطى العرب حيث العوده
الى التراث ونبش الماضي وتاريخ ارضنا
المتجذر
وفي برنامج مقابله خاصه انتقلنا للمواجهه
مع صناع القرار وناقشنا القضايا الانيه
وقدم برنامج الندوه نموذجا للحوار الحضاري
في الموضوعات الاكثر جدلا بمهنيه وحرفيه
عاليه ولان ما يدور حولنا يؤثر فينا
ونتاثر به فقد ذهبنا الى قراءه الاحداث من
حولنا ورؤيتها من وجهات نظر مختلفه في
برنامج البعد الاخر كما طرحنا الاسئله بلا
تردد فكان سؤال مباشر ايضا بين البرامج
الذين لا محتواه نصيبه من التقدير كما حضر
برنامج روافد كشاهد على ابداعات فنانين
وكتاب ومبدعين عرب
سعت العربيه لتصنع من الكلمه والصوره
محتوا يليق بالمتلقي فاصبحت قبلته الاولى
ورسخت مكانتها في العصر الرقمي وانطلقت
بقوالب الاعلام الجديد عبر صفحات المنصات
الاجتماعيه المختلفه فحصدت مزيدا من
الجوائز لا تعبروا الا عن فريقا يجتهد
للافضل ومحركه الشغف في مهنه المتاعب
اليوم تدخل خزائن العربيه جوائز جديده
لتشكل لابنائها دافعا نحو الاستمراريه في
الابداع وذلك لهدف واحد هو ان تعرف اكثر
[موسيقى]